ich habe heute einen tag lang nur in
restaurants gegessen die noch nicht
bewertet wurden zumindest noch nicht auf
tripadvisor weil ich gehe immer nach
tripadvisor bei den ganzen bewertungs
videos und der gedanke ist daraus
entstanden dass mir dachte ich kann der
erste sein der eine bewertung schreibt
egal wie gut oder schlecht das
restaurant ist und dass er mir gemacht
dreimal essen gewesen war wieder ein
sehr anstrengender tag danke dass ihr
die videos möglich macht und viel spaß
mit dem video wir sind beim ersten namen
angekommen und er kam mir so bekannt vor
vom namen das hatten ganz bestimmten
grund wenn wir einmal drüber schauen die
kaffee faktor ist nämlich direkt neben
der caruso passt aber wo wir letztens
veranlasst die feste pasta in köln
popstars aussagt über den kaffee keine
ahnung und über das essen wir test
natürlich beides werden hunger es ist
früh und wir das nicht schmecken
hoffentlich hat es nun schmecken ich
habe eine schöne maschine damals sockel
[Musik]
hallo
sehr sehr schön frostig durch sehr schön
respekt und verdursten zutaten auf super
einzige kannst du gleich mal probieren
noch etwas aus dem fenster schmeckt ein
bisschen nach außen flaschen also ich
meine es viele ward aber also man kann
halt auch gut ist was mich fertig
schmecken kaufen aber es ist super
lecker also dafür dass wir alles auf dem
gesamten spektrum hätten bekommen können
kommen genug sein bitte weiß man da rein
decker glücks die textur der crunch
nochmal am mikro
das geil oder ernst also kann man gar
nichts sagen aber
das ist ja auch so ja ich hole mir dazu
vor der uni hat was war mit dem wagen
morgens perfekt was will ich mehr sagte
was ist die alternative
53 72 mitten in köln porz notwendig
jetzt sagen weißt du wo geht man günstig
frühstück und günstigen
das ist das krasseste was ich jetzt
machen aber es ist kann auch nicht alles
eine fünf sterne von prinz sein so weißt
du aber solange jemand einfach was
korrekt es auf den tisch bringt das ist
doch geil café gesondert einer bewertung
außergewöhnlichsten cappuccino
eigentlich hätte wird einen kleineren
gerüstet aber ich krieg mehr
für weniger geld als sonstwo deshalb
diesmal vor dem bus aus hast du jetzt
geschrieben hier nehmen mit dem alter
café bus panino netter laden und belebte
lage firma wenn es schnell gehen muss
gerne 45 wenn es schnell gehen muss ist
übrigens ein gutes stichwort weil man
hat ja nicht immer zeit essen zu gehen
selbst wenn es schnell gehen muss und da
habe ich was fällt als ich die mail von
giovanni rana in meinem postfach gesehen
habe war ich erst mal kritisch wie ihr
euch denken könnt bin ich recht
anspruchsvoll messen und ich war mir
nicht sicher ob es für eine fertig
mahlzeit werden kann aber das musste ich
gar nicht was sie hier sehen die pasta
kids von giovanni rana sind keine
fertigmahlzeiten es sind vielmehr
ultraschnelle pasta gerichte mit
frischen nudeln die man zuhause
komplettiert giovanni rana ist stolz
eine italienische marke zu sein und das
merkt man an den zutaten und an der
innovativen herangehensweise um ein
altbekanntes problem zu lösen zuhause
leckeres essen mit wenig zeit zu
genießen die frische nudeln werden in
der jeweiligen soße für wenige minuten
gekocht und nach fünf minuten hat man
einen warmen teller mit frischer pasta
von sich aber lassen wir die pasta für
sich selbst sprechen
[Musik]
wir haben alle sorten gemeinsam im büro
probiert und ich war wirklich positiv
überrascht wie gut die tastatur kein
spaß probiert sie gerne mal aus und
lassen mich wissen wie es schmeckt ach
so und in den pubs jetzt ist übrigens
auch noch käse und getrocknete kräuter
dabei also das ist das ganze
fertigmachen und schön anrichten
[Musik]
noch voll lecker geht superschnell oder
nächstes mein favorit viel spaß mit den
weiteren video das immer wieder freunde
zweiter
zweiter standort hier sind bei fremd
eingesammelt
diese akkus eine sache die ich noch nie
gegessen habe aber mit der ich schon
gehört haben weist aber nicht viel
darüber was man wie die aussehen und das
sieht man auch direkt an der
außenwerbung deshalb würde ich sagen was
sagst du von außen lage ist krank und
schon sagen nein also an dem eingang von
einem supermarkt zu sein ist schon ja
also für gelegenheits kundschaft jetzt
mehr für diese auf hand und einer aus
togo
war ja dann schauen wir erstmal
[Musik]
das sieht schon so richtig
auf so trey damit so ein papier hier
darauf stehe ich ja womöglich selbst
wenn er das gebiss und das hier ist also
der french cancan wir haben drin so die
pole soße die jede menge pommes und auch
die chicken tenders und längerem ringen
ich möchte mir gegangen es riecht so als
könnte ist sehr lecker welt
probieren wir
auf jeden fall viel was abgeht naja was
denkst du warst du erlebst du auf den
satz hier erfüllt mit chicken tales die
soße mit pommes beißt aber ich sage
ehrlich richtig saftig ehrlich gemeinte
dafür muss muss frei sein das ist fett
und das sind karten schicken tenders auf
stabil muss man wirklich sagen schicken
international saftig hochschule
vielleicht noch mal gut und das ist so
ein ding damit machst du dich fertig das
besteht ist so wenn du weißt so der tag
vorbei der soll vorbei sein
so haben es
sehr gut sports männersache aber es muss
ein bisschen über die tag und nacht
ich habe ich es zum ersten mal wenig
direkte not a film ist erst jetzt auch
dann sehen wir uns und dann wäre da auch
schon genommen das gesetz leute alles
weg erika pohl ist aber ich muss
wirklich sagen positiv überrascht ich
war sehr kritisch muss ich sagen und
eine befürchtung ist auch eingetreten
nämlich dass das ganze sehr homogen wird
so du hast keinen textur unterschied
mehr du hast keine christen aus der
sonne alles wird so ein bisschen weich
public aber das ist überraschend je
länger man das ist desto mehr sagt dein
kopf aus mehr davon sagt er so ok ich
hoffe dir mehr von dem feld separaten
rennen und irgendwie ich bin für so was
zu haben ich liebe es hier auch im smash
burger mir rein zu hemmen und so ist
schon gut was wir ja gerade meine suchen
genau das gleiche produkt übels gestylt
und umnutzung eines teilt vielleicht
noch ein bisschen mehr raffinesse in der
zusammenstellung dann kann doch baden in
so einer eigenen kategorie schon 55 ja
es ist wirklich lecker riecht ich würde
ja auch jedem empfehlen der mann die
klinge hat ausprobieren naja schmeckt
super ist das neues ich lieb' sowieso
neue sachen zu entdecken und nur hat sie
sozusagen zusammenstellen wie das mag
ist ja das packen wir es eine kurze
bewertung kommen wir zur bewertung ich
gebe ebenfalls vier von fünf punkten ist
scheiße dass man nicht besser
differenzieren kann weil das heute
morgen hätte ich gesagt waren ticken
besser und man kann halt nur ganze
punkte vergeben deshalb ist das relativ
und differenziert vielleicht fange ich
in zukunft einmal irgendwie so meine
persönliche bewertung mit komma zahl
einzublenden aber das habe ich
geschrieben wilde kombinationen man
fragt sich auch das schmecken kann und
das tut es die einzelnen zutaten gehen
teilweise ein wenig runter im takko aber
dass das gar nicht weiter stimmen
funktioniert lecker wir sehen uns wieder
beim abendessen ist dämmert ich hab
hunger die letzte station für den
heutigen tag down to earth modus das
irritiert mich ein bisschen wenn ich mir
dieses schild da angucke weil man kann
es kaum noch lesen
also warum ist es nicht wert sind sie
auf leute drehen gleich und bewertungs
würdig ich habe glaube ich ein gutes
gefühl wir sind ja wirklich heute nur
nach den namen der restaurants werden
wir wollten natürlich das bestmögliche
finden und sind nur auf den namen
gegangen ist spannend
ok also nur vom namen her dass das
italienische pasta
diese
teig täschchen die so viel dampf links
remis schon wieder somit interessante
reisen heute jedes mal wir haben also
insbesondere heute zwei sache weil wenn
das jetzt keine rahmen sind habe ich
keine ahnung ist das ist was wir nehmen
sollen wir morgen oder bee flat classic
ist glaube ich gut was ist austestet
habe mir gelandet ich bin vorher
schlagen alter das sieht vor allem
sowieso übels szeneladen der so voll
bekannt ist sieht aber auch so auskommen
ich finde es sieht so aus als sei dieser
laden stück für stück gewachsen so es
ist einfach so immer so ein neues stück
dazugekommen wissen auch schon wieder
draußen geschaut ich würde oder wir
würden einmal die beef classic modus
nehmen wie kommen die sind ist das sind
das einfach nudeln ist das eine fahrer
ist es also suppen mäßig will nudeln
nudeln in der brühe in der frühe mit
welchem land kommen die tibet tibet
als damals und das thema dann einmal die
beef classic und einmal die momo
rindfleisch fünf stück beschreibt
kampusch ja
das ist dann fermentierter t der wird
mit einem pilz angereist schmeckt
intensiv aber erfrischend
[Musik]
diesmal wird loki ball nicht so richtig
zu fleisch richtig richtig kräftig hier
kann man mit so einem laken mit so einem
stoff tun mit seiner einlage zum dämpfen
redest du so mit chilisoße ich musste
man nicht gegessen haben ich weiß schon
krass man sieht man riecht man fühlt
dass das einfach traditionell ist ja
letztendlich authentisch das richtige
wort
[Musik]
also ich hab mir grad erklären lassen
man beißt einmal auf da schon noch ein
bisschen brühe drin kann man dann aus
schlürfen
das ist quasi automatisch mal rein ins
ziel und da
[Musik]
zitronengras ingwer würziges fleisch ach
so was frisches vielleicht so winziges
kräftige brühe scharfes chili vor
das ist um mal krank und haben so eine
richtige konsistenz
die sind so geil zu essen das ist krank
das gericht rang 11 das alles sieht
einfach geil aus ist die story top set
ist für eine ausnahme die sind von hand
wer hat's gesehen
diese berührende
angeles bestimmt authentisch
so werden auch die nudeln die wir testen
müssen ich bin sehr gespannt also
mittlerweile
sehr viel sehr sehr ich gehe mal hier so
runter wo alles du in dieser brühl
schwimmen konnte nudeln wie die momo
sieht man direkt sind auch selbst
gemacht also jetzt alles elektrische
nudeln ist das ist rang qualität in der
48 mit brühe ohne irgendwas frisches da
oben drauf auch
sehr krass
klassentreffen ist gar nicht so leicht
zu den modellen mit stäbchen zu essen
das bietet gleich blieb
ich muss das ganze gleich bewerten aber
ich habe schon so eine vorahnung was das
hier wird es ist wirklich rundum geil
hier also meine geile überraschung
komplett fertig war schon man fühlt sich
gut von der szenerie wie im urlaub es
ist technisch was neues was soll ich
sagen leute krönender abschluss kommen
wir zur bewertung perfekt für jeden der
raus fällt aus dem kulinarischen und
gastronomischen alltag bewährt weil sie
in 30 minuten ohne jemals gewesen zu
sein frische zutaten mit liebe gekocht
und super in szene gesetzt damit hätte
ich nicht gerechnet 5 von 5 punkten
das war wirklich ein krönender abschluss
ich habe es gerade schon gesagt es war
einfach geil also das war absolut mein
highlight heute und auch die anderen
waren wirklich nicht von schlechten
eltern also es waren beides läden zu
denen ich wieder gehen würde wenn sie es
ergibt aber wo ich jetzt nicht gezielt
hingehen würde der letzte war wirklich
krass da will ich auf jeden fall wieder
hingehen und ja insgesamt auf jeden fall
mal wieder ne geile erfahrung danke fürs
zu sehen wir sehen uns beim nächsten
video wieder das gern gleich und 1
kommentar das beste